c'est un honneur c'est un véritable
honneur de voir son nom
ces photos des photos et affiches de mes
films un cinéaste canada ecclésiaste
lemba est de retour sur ses terres
natales enfin de la ville des mureaux il
revient pour la projection de deux de
ses films le dernier un documentaire
voyage vers mes racines tournée en
république démocratique du congo d'où
elle est originaire
[Musique]
cela peut porter que j'ai produit donc
sur mon premier voyage à vers la terre
de mes ancêtres donc ce documentaire
sera projeté avec mon deuxième film
pardon je m'excuse en deuxième film qui
s'intitule welcome tôt montréal ces deux
films seront projetés au cinéma frédéric
dard le vendredi 1er avril à 20 heures
lors du festival du film francophone
pour la jeunesse qui aura lieu du mardi
29 mars au dimanche 3 avril aux mureaux
et dont ecclésiaste lenga et les parents
toujours à un plaisir de croiser des
amis des personnes qui me connaissent
qu'ils me voient la télé qui ne voit
dans les films et qui me demande parfois
comment ça va si quand tu fais un fil au
bureau bon tu vas me dire quand est ce
que jeu tournera un film au bureau mais
en tout cas pourquoi pas un jour au
programme de cette première édition une
sélection de films francophones venus du
monde entier mais aussi des ateliers
l'atelier de doublage de montage de
tournage également le concours de courts
métrages pour les jeunes des mureaux
ouvert à tous donc je pense que ce sera
l'occasion de fêter le septième art dans
cette ville des mureaux quoi c'est une
ville dynamique jeune le concours de
courts métrages et gratuit ouvert à tous
et sans limite d'âge samedi 2 avril à
20h45 l'ensemble des courts métrages
sera visible au cinéma frédéric dard
suivie d'une remise de prix